- I'm Dave Sasson
alongside Jeff Worthing,
and welcome to the 2013
East/West Bowl,
where we're going
to be watching
some of the best college
athletes in the nation
try to put last year's spectacle
to shame.
- That's right, Dave.
It won't be easy,
but this year's seniors
certainly will be trying
to give last year's stars
a run for their money.
Let's check out the teams,
starting with the players
from the east.
[energetic rock music]
- Coznesster Smiff,
Rutgers University.
- Elipses Corter,
University of Alabama.
- Nyquillus Dillwad, L.S.U.
- Bismo Funyuns,
Florida State University.
- Decatholac Mango,
Georgia Tech University.
- Mergatroid Skittle,
University of Louisville.
- Quiznatodd Bidness,
University of Tennessee.
- D'Pez Poopsie, Ole Miss.
- Quackadilly Blip,
Auburn University.
- Goolius Boozler, the "U."
- Bisquiteen Trisket,
University of Michigan.
- Fartrell Cluggins,
University of Arkansas.
- Blyrone Blashinton,
Syracuse.
- Cartoons Plural,
Virginia Tech.
- Jammie Jammie-Jammie,
the Ohio State University.
- Fudge.
- Some of the big stories
this year--
the meteoric rise
of D'Pez Poopsie,
and let's not forget
about Heisman winner
Jammie Jammie-Jammie.
- And remember, you can't talk
about 2013
without bringing up Fudge.
Everybody's talking
about Fudge.
At 350 pounds,
this running back
is almost unstoppable
the whole year.
- You're right. I could talk
about Fudge all day.
But first, let's meet
the players from the west.
[energetic rock music]
- Equine Ducklings,
Indiana University,
Purdue University,
Indianapolis.
- Dahistorius Lamystorius,
Utah State University.
- Ewokoniad Sigourneth
Juniorstein,
Oklahoma State University.
- Eqqsquizitine
Buble-Schwinslow,
University of Nebraska.
- Huka'Lakanaka
Hakanakaheekalucka'hukahakafaka,
University of Hawaii.
- King Prince Chambermaid,
Baylor University.
- Ladennifer Jadaniston,
University of Colorado.
- Ladadadaladadadadada
Dala-dadaladaladalada,
University of Arizona.
- Harvard University,
Devry University.
- [imitating rapid beeping]
Army/Navy Surplus Store.
- Wingdings, Online Classes.
- [distorted voice]
Firstname Lastname,
College University.
- God,
Homeschool.
- Squeeeeeeeeeeps,
Santa Monica College.
- [British accent]
Benedict Cumberbatch,
Oxford University.
- A.A. Ron Balakay,
Morehouse College.